lorsque vous étiez à villepinte vous
avez dit que vous aviez été élevé par
votre grand mère par l'autre mère
et vous avez manifestement beaucoup de
respect pour elle
je voudrais vous dire combien en tant
que femme je me sens blessé et humilié
lorsque vous parlez de cette
intelligence inférieur lorsque vous
dites que nous sommes des buts et des
buts 1
lorsque vous prétendez que
la discrimination positive qui
n'existent pas par ailleurs parce que
dès lors qu'il ya discrimination
elle ne peut pas être positives eh bien
je voudrais vous dire que les femmes de
ce pays
contribuent à faire de la france ce
qu'elle est je voudrais que vous dire
que les femmes ne choisissent pas
contrairement à ce que vous dites elles
ne choisissent pas de faire des métiers
qui sont les moins valorisés les moins
reconnu des métiers sous payés je
voudrais vous dire que sans les femmes
de notre pays pendant cette crise
sanitaire eh bien nous n'aurions pas eu
d'infirmières nous n'aurions pas eu de
femmes dans les ehpad pour aider nos
personnes âgées et je voudrais vous dire
que la raison pour laquelle ce
gouvernement
a eu à soutenir cette loi pour les
quotas c'est parce que nous voulons
réparer des injustices que les femmes
subissent depuis trop longtemps
maintenant voilà ce que je voudrais vous
dire monsieur est mort et je pense qu'il
est important puisque je crois que vous
êtes père d'une fille et deux garçons je
voudrais vous dire que je serai
extrêmement étonné que vous acceptiez
que votre fille lorsqu'elle sera en âge
de travailler si ce n'est pas encore le
cas soit payée 16,5 pour cent en moins
que son frère juste parce que c'est une
fille voilà ce que je voudrais vous dire
monsieur et moi alors eric zemmour alors
je suis à peu près d'accord avec 80% de
ce que vous avez dit vous allez
rejoindre le gouvernement l'an pas du
tout mais
pardonnez moi mais vous avez dit des
banalités avec lesquels que je ne peux
être que d'accord que les femmes par
exemple ont fait la france oui comme les
hommes depuis mille des millions des
milliers d'années oui on peut même dire
que vous savez sous la monarchie tous
les observateurs européens disaient ce
pays est incroyable ce sont les femmes
qui règne certains ont même dit que la
révolution française qu'admire temps mon
futur
contradicteurs de la france a soumises
alexis avait mis un terme à eau au règne
des femmes sous la monarchie et que ce
c'est la révolution française qui avait
renvoyé les femmes à la maison que ces
mêmes robespierre que monsieur corbières
admire tant qui les a renvoyés à la
maison donc vous voyez et réjean donc
vous voyez je donc nous sommes capables
de tenir le pouvoir et qui a dit le
contraire alors
je connais je connais catherine de
russie vous savez je connais madame
thatcher eric zemmour je vous avais dit
sur bfm en 2013 dans les milieux où il
ya vraiment le pouvoir il n'y a pas de
femmes
vous savez je vais vous dire quelque
chose c'est un petit jeu avec lequel on
joue depuis décidé d'aider semaine par
la joue depuis des années mais
maintenant c'est un autre sens de
prendre une phrase par ci par là que
j'ai écrite il ya quatre ans 5 ans 10
ans et d'en faire l'exégèse jeu j'ai
l'habitude maintenant de citer la phrase
de richelieu qui disait donnez-moi trois
phrases de n'importe qui et je le fais
et exécutés non c'est normalement c'est
difficile à faire donc moi je vous dis
il y a aujourd'hui je suis le candidat
donc le candidat n'a absolument prix et
ne prendra aucune mesure contre les
femmes et contre l'égalité et vous avez
dit que vous reviendriez sur la parité
mais j'ai dit que l'ap mais la parité
n'est pas selon moi une bonne mesure
elle est humiliante pour les femmes la
cérémonie organisée soyez gentils
laissez moi parler je vous ai laissé
parler sagement alors que j'étais en
désaccord avec une phrase sur trois donc
vous voyez non vous avez donné une
phrase sur quatre allez vous attend vous
êtes tombé à 25 %
donc je disais donc que
la parité qu'est ce que c'est
c'est prendre une femme pour ce qu'elle
est et non pas pour ce qu'elle fait
excusez moi c'est humiliant pour les
femmes et c'est humiliant pour ce que
vous défendez c'est à dire le fait que
les femmes comme vous l'avait dit et
comme je suis d'accord avec vous ont une
intelligence évidemment peuvent
évidemment reprendre tous les rôles
toutes les fonctions tous les métiers
donc elles n'ont pas besoin
elles n'ont pas besoin d'avoir une
mesure de discrimination positive parce
que vous le vouliez ou non ça s'appelle
de la discrimination positive en tout
cas c'est la traduction qu'on en fait du
mécanisme inventé par des américains
donc ça veut dire que
favorise les femmes parce qu'elles sont
femmes moi je considère que les femmes
comme vous l'avez dit on une
intelligence bien et galop à celle des
hommes et donc peuvent avoir les mêmes
métiers que les hommes et donc et donc
il n'y a pas besoin assez loin velde son
charme à 2 mais j'ai toujours dit ça
abonde vous êtes encore une fois mais
bien sûr mais il n'avait pas dit ça mais
il ya une différence il ya une
différence madame raynault ya une
différence c'est que moi j'estime que
une femme n'est pas un homme et qu'un
homme n'est pas une femme mais j'en suis
parfaitement consciente et ben voilà
c'est je suis une femme et je ne suis
pas vous monsieur et ben voila vous je
suis concierge et nous sommes d'accord
alors est-ce que vous vous demandez une
chose est ce que vous êtes féministe est
ce que je suis féministe parce que
féministe oui je me demande si vous êtes
féministe écoutez je si vous avez
répondu tout le monde vous êtes vous
avez un peu un discours contre fait mine
bruit je verrais que
le féminisme qu'est ce que c'est
si c'est
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
je suis féministe comme les autres en
revanche si c'est l'indifférenciation
entre les hommes et les femmes je ne
suis pas féministe si c'est la phrase
célèbre de simone de beauvoir qui est à
l'origine du féminisme on n'est pas
femme on le devient
je ne suis pas féministe je pense qu'on
es femmes et qu'on le devient parce
qu'on est né femme et qu'on devient
homme parce qu'on est né sommes donc
vous voyez c'est assez simple en fait
alors vous voyez je suis très heureuse
d'être venue ce soir parce que je n'a
jamais jamais lorsque vous avez écrit le
premier sexe jamais je n'aurais cru un
seul instant que vous diriez que vous
étiez féministe aujourd'hui j'ai dit que
je n'étais pas là la réponse si vous
voulez déterministe je pense que vous
devriez revoir ce que vous avez écrit
dans le premier sexe et vous vous
rendriez compte que les femmes ne sont
pas ceux que vous avez décrit dans ce
livre et je voudrais également vous
poser une question
vous vous dites que vous êtes contre la
parité que vous en vous êtes contre les
discriminations positives
est ce que vous considérez
que aujourd'hui les femmes sont traitées
comme les hommes dans notre pays oui
véritablement avec égalité les femmes
sont traitées et guy là et de manière
égalitaire mais bien sûr avec les hommes
mais bien est-ce que les mêmes droits
que les femmes que les hommes et vous
que oui dans tous les domaines dans tous
leurs tous les domaines de la société
les femmes semblent y était comme elle
est si chère madame d'accord est-ce que
vous pensez que loi c 10 ans larry quinn
qui
comprenons leur métier est-ce que
choisissent librement s'il avait les
femmes décident d'occuper les métiers
les moins reconnu les moins valorisés
les moins payés vous pensez qu'une femme
décide d'être femme de ménage de partir
de chez elle à 6 heures du matin de
laisser ses enfants de rentrer lorsque
ces enfants ne sont pas à la maison et
de repartir ensuite à 18 heures alors
que ses enfants vont rentrer à la maison
est-ce que vous pensez que les femmes
choisissent de gagner moins que les
hommes est ce que vous pensez que les
femmes choisissent d'être assassiné tous
les trois jours par des hommes est ce
que vous considérez est ce que répond la
vallée la chaussée mois terminée à
terminer est ce que vous pensez
véritablement qu'aujourd'hui le
président de la république aurait eu à
choisir l'égalité femmes hommes comme la
grande cause du quinquennat si les
femmes étaient véritablement traité
comme des hommes dans notre pays alors
madame aurait lors ya beaucoup de
questions il ya beau exactement je vous
remercie de leur goût de le remarquer je
sais compter
d'abord
je ne crois pas que les hommes se lèvent
plus tard que les femmes je ne crois pas
que les hommes travaillent moins que les
femmes je ne comprends pas déjà votre
première distinction la 2d la deuxième
oui je pense que les femmes choisissent
leur métier elles choisissent d'être
infirmière oui elles choisissent d'être
institutrice oui elles choisissent
d'être médecin oui elle choisit là vous
prenez des exemples eric c'est pas su
pas de choc par l'elysée attendaient une
femme de ménage il ya des hommes
d'éboueurs il ya des hommes qui peuvent
excuser moi il ya des zones qui sont
aussi au bas de l'échelle qu'est ce que
c'est que cette distinction il ya des
femmes de ménage il ya aussi des hommes
de ménage yahiya ddd des zones qui sont
au bas de l'échelle et qui gagnent la
majorité des métiers essentiels de notre
pays puis nous l'avons vu madame reno
pour cent ciels la majorité tous les
métiers sont essentiels à fait vraiment
dans un gouvernement la cia le ton de
distinguer entre les essais officiels et
les noms des anciennes suisse et la
grande spécialité de votre gouvernement
sage ronarc'h fait si vous voulez
vraiment une habitude héritée rythmera
méfier tgv est ce que vous êtes pour ce
que vous êtes pour l'égalité des
salaires entre un métier égal et à
qualification égale et à travail égal
parce que tous les êtres premier
ministre d'une femme bien sûr vous savez
que dans ma dans ma vie professionnelle
de journaliste j'ai eu des femmes chefs
de service ça m'a jamais gêné et vous
reconnaissiez leur talent ou connaissiez
leurs compétences avait moins je ne
connais que la compétence et le mérite